I don't know what's the first step in
writing a screenplay it's getting the
idea it's sitting down and it's pulling
out from you and it's beginning to you
know pull the material together many
times people do outline sometimes they
do treatment sometimes they just get a
couple paragraphs of a story and then
look at it and say do I actually have a
beginning middle and end and do I have a
story so many people think that they
have the next big idea which is great in
they're enthusiastic about it when
should they then let others know so they
can bounce that not not too quickly
because you you need to sort of feel
your way through it it's not like it
comes to you full-blown generally so you
shouldn't hurry the process now
sometimes you might say I have five
ideas and you write them all in one
paragraph and then you say well which
one is the best maybe at that point you
might ask somebody to say what do you
see going on here I'm not sure what
direction but if you really have
something pushing at you you know
something that's really heating up
there's an advantage to working it out a
bit and not letting people get in too
early because you don't want criticism
too early you want the flow is and you
want the excitement and the passion and
finding your way and even through a
draft or two you're probably still
finding your way to the story but then
there is a point you do need that
verification or evaluation from somebody
outside yourself and who would that be
because a mother a father sister
brothers probably will say it yes yes
well one of the first things to do is to
have friends who are writers and make
sure that they are constructive so you
don't want to give this to somebody who
reads your script and says oh no you
want to read it to send and say okay I
can see exactly where its swords I
sometimes recommend that readers look
for where are they excited where are
they reading it and they feeling the
flow because it may not flow all the way
through yeah
as still as to be rewritten at some
point many people do go to script
consultant and a script consultant is
meant to be the objective professional I
and again you want to find a positive
constructive script consultant not
someone who's there to tear it apart
you're there that's supposed to be there
to build it up instead
you